I tracked the lives of 5,000 people as they attempted to achieve their New Year's resolutions.
Now most of them failed, but ten percent did obtain their aims and ambitions.
But what were they doing was so different.
But it all came down to five simple principles.
First of all, they broke their goal into a series of smaller steps.
Second, they told their friends and family what they were trying to achieve.
So that elicited more of a fear of failure but also a sense of support.
Third, they frequently reminded themselves about the benefits of obtaining their goal.
Fourth, they gave themselves a small reward each time they obtain one of their small steps.
And finally, they mapped out their progress.
Either on the spreadsheet, on the fridge door or in a journal.
So, they knew exactly where they were.
And those are the five key principles to actually achieving your New Year's resolutions.